>>> Just minutes ago the cross-examination
of prince Harry resumed after a break. He's
taking the witness stand saying some British
tabloids have, quote, blood on their hands
for the distress they have caused him growing
up and for the death of his mother, princess
Diana. It's incredibly rare for a senior royal
to testify in court, in fact, until now it
hasn't happened since 1891, that's more than
100 years. Harry alleges mirror group newspapers
hacked his phone and used other illicit means
to get information about his life for stories.
CNN's max foster is following the trial for
us, he joins us now from London. What are
you hearing from today's testimony? What stood
out?
>> Reporter: It is extraordinary watching
T I am able to watch it through a virtual
camera and watching him being grilled like
that, up don't see Royals in that situation,
it's a cross-examination, his broad
[9:23:15 AM]
cross-examination, his broad argument is that
as he was growing up from the age of 12 his
phone was being hacked, people around him's
phones were being hacked and those -- the
information from that hacking was used in
tabloid stories, taken together they caused
a huge amount of distress for him growing
up and his circle of friends shrunk because
he couldn't trust anyone anymore. That's his
broad argument. What the barrister for the
mirror group newspapers is doing is trying
to undermine each and every article that prince
Harry points to. He will say, for example,
do you remember reading this article, Harry
will say I don't remember reading the article
and then the bare wrister said how could it
have caused stress and stress for you. Pointing
out a lot of the information in these articles
was already in the public and had been confirmed
by the palace. A tough grilling for Harry
on the detail. He's making a much broader
point here, his mission, Sara, is to reform
the British tabloid media.
>> I want to ask you about a situation here
in the states, prince Harry is involved in
a lawsuit here over his Visa.
[9:24:17 AM]
lawsuit here over his Visa. What can you tell
us about that?
>> Reporter: So this is a think tank the heritage
foundation has gone to a federal court, wants
access to Harry's Visa application. The reason
for that is they want to see whether or not
he declared his drug use that he admitted
to in his book "Spare." If he did, why did
he get a waiver. If he didn't, does that mean
the Visa still holds? That will be interesting.
I don't think we will get the result today
but the media has
Landmark, and his story, prince Harry's showdown
with the uk tabloid press reaching a new level
today. The senior British royal heading into
court earlier, and then taking the witness
stand. In his lawsuit against mirror group
newspapers, which is a major uk newspaper
publisher. Harry alleges his phone was hacked
to gather information about his private life,
and Diane is contesting those claims. Let's
get to CNN's Noah Bashir who is outside the
uk high court in central London. We did finally
hear from prince Harry, on what is day two
of the case. Obviously, didn't make it to
court yesterday, what did we hear from him?
>> Well Becky, prince Harry has gone into
the details of his witness statement, outlining
the impact of the medias
[10:12:55 AM]
the impact of the medias intrusion, the British
tabloid under and GM has had on his life.
And growing up. He is now currently undergoing
cross examination, and rain, the right barrister
representing mgn, taking some questions to
the court of the impact that the mirror group
newspapers publications have had on prince
Harry. A lot of questions as to how he could've
been distressed by some of these articles
if they were written and publish at a time
where he was very young, perhaps reading these
articles, questions as to why prince Harry
has taken issue with some of these articles,
when in fact, similar statements have been
made and released by the palace itself. They
are currently going through a number of articles
that prince Harry has submitted as part of
his payment. Over 147 articles published in
the early 1990s and thousand 11 were submitted
as part of -- 33 are being considered and
heard by the court at the moment. They have
just reached article number 13.
[10:13:56 AM]
number 13. Of course, as you mentioned, prince
Harry and his legal team allege that the mirror
group newspapers used unlawful practices in
order to obtain private information. That
includes phone hacking, intercepting voicemails,
and even using private investigators to leak
information about prince Harry's activities,
and those of those around him. And he spoke
by the impacts, how it made his friendship
group smaller and smaller as a result of paranoia.
He suffered from bouts of depression, this
eventually led to the breakdown some of his
relationships, including that of his relationship
between himself and his former longtime girlfriend,
Chelsea Davey. And of course, mgm has contested
these claims, they say that they were not
aware of any wrongdoing by their journalists,
at the time. But they also contests that there
are simply no evidence at this -- that prince
Harry himself was hacked, and it back, that
has been a repeated question now, by Andrew
-- the bears to representing mgn in court
over the last few hours, questions as to how
prince Harry and his legal team have come
to the assertion that
[10:14:56 AM]
have come to the assertion that hacking was
in fact use, or other unlawful measures were
used to clean information featured in some
of these articles. He has reference quotes
that -- people from the palace including -- just
the last couple of hours, one example used
a story published around prince Harry suffering
from glandular fever and prince Harry himself
telling the court that he believed the timing
of this article with suspicious, he believes
that the quotes used in this article could
only have been known through gathering information
through illegal means, mgn's lawyer pulling
out a quote from saint James palace confirming
that this was true. Some real questions here,
at that's hearing is set to continue, prince
Harry will